hello everybody and welcome back to
another Raspberry Pi tutorial in this
tutorial we're going to be talking about
how to turn your Raspberry Pi into a
webserver now the Raspberry Pi really
isn't
well the Raspberry Pi itself is actually
a decent web server I mean you could run
it pretty probably like 90% of the
websites on the Internet today it could
be run off a Raspberry Pi the actual
weak spot is your SD card because the SD
card isn't really built for bulk read
and write operations which websites do
frequently especially if you have say
like a wordpress blog with comments
where you've got like a forum or
something like I like you couldn't you
just couldn't do it you would just you'd
kill your SD card so it's not really
going to be a functional website you
could make a pretty decent static
website off of it but instead what you
will get from this is simply a ton of
educational value just like pretty much
everything with the Raspberry Pi means
great teaching device you know if I was
a professor and I was teaching classes
either on like super computers
networking web server kind of stuff I
mean you wouldn't need a textbook you
would need a Raspberry Pi and they're so
cheap that you can get one you know
especially when it comes like super
computers it's like ok we'll buy like 16
of the raspberry PI's eing of it you
have a supercomputer or a decent amount
to at least test networking on and all
kinds of stuff so anyway so while it
won't necessarily be like a wonderful
website for a web server for you instead
what it'll do is actually teach you how
to how to work with a web server like if
you have like a VPS or something for a
website instead of paying hundreds and
hundred dollars a month to get like a
managed VPS just manage it yourself or
you could later get a job you know
managing web servers as you learn more
about them so anyways it's really just
for teaching I wouldn't suggest you use
these websites just yet but all
showing you guys pretty much all the
stuff that's required for a web server
and by the end of this we'll at least
have a basic web page displayed so with
that let's go ahead and hop right on
into it you don't have to go to your
desktop by the way for most of my
tutorials I just go to it just in case
people are uncomfortable with starting
into the terminal but basically what
we're going to be using is just the
terminal so either if you go straight to
your desktop on startup then open up
your terminal and if not you don't have
to be in your terminal or I mean you
have to be in your desktop rather so
anyways let's go ahead and get started
now before we actually start installing
stuff and making up a page we have to do
it really just most of this is a lot of
housekeeping so the first thing we want
to do is consider memory split if you're
running off of a older version of
Raspberry Pi you definitely want to do a
firmware update if you plan to turn your
Raspberry Pi into some sort of web
server this is because you can utilize
memory splits basically which is which
will allow your GPU in your processor to
interact with each other like the memory
between them will now be dynamic or
actually I'm sorry you have a newer
version it's it already is dynamic but
you can set the limits of you know when
does the process or start pulling and
how much can the processor point and so
on so anyway once you one of the things
that you can do immediately is go into
sudo rasped by - config and that should
launch up your it's not a BIOS but I
think of it like one a lot and what
you're going to want to do is go into
Advanced Options and in there you should
see memory split and so we'll hit that
and we really don't need 64 if you're
gonna run a web server you just don't
need that so instead what we're gonna do
is we're gonna back this up and change
it to 16 now for the purposes of just
learning how to set up a web server you
don't really need to do that but since
we are kind of just trying to teach you
all this stuff might as well do
everything right so we're hit okay and
it might I think it's going
want to restart after we do this let's
see yeah it's gonna want to reboot so go
ahead and hit yes and go through the
reboot process and if you don't go to
desktop don't worry about star X just
waiting your terminal and we'll ring
meet once once my PI has rebooted all
right guys welcome back I actually
forgot to do one more thing if we want
to be a true web server we actually need
one more change but that's okay let me
go ahead and go through it anyways it
might want another reboot but sorry guys
so anyway go back into your rest by -
config here and what we want to go into
is again Advanced Options and what we
want to do is enable SSH it's pretty
much the better way to be connecting
your server you can look around and find
out like FTP and stuff and if you've
ever dealt with having a web site and
stuff hopefully that's anyway if you've
ever dealt with having web so you've
probably used FTP before but it's
actually not the most secure way to or
it's not the most accurate on your your
web server so if security is of any
concern at all probably better just to
stick with purely SSH but anyway that's
hit finish see if I've got a reboot
it doesn't look like it looks like it
just starts it I'm not sure if it will
start it every on every boot or not but
I bet it would so anyways let's go ahead
and continue on it's a nice bit of
housekeeping that we really need to take
care of is getting Debian up-to-date and
then we need to make sure we're up to
date on our firmware now if you guys
have been following my tutorials chances
are you're up-to-date on your firmware
but there's actually a quicker way to
update your firmware that I found out so
we'll go through the quicker way and now
you guys can update your firmware much
easier than like literally typing in
that hash code so anyways let's go ahead
and get started with updating that the
code here is going to be first we want
to do sudo dpkg
-
configure TZ data and this is gonna be
for a time zone data so you'll be able
to choose what time zone your PI is are
your now your web server so you will
want to choose wherever you are in my
case I'm in the United States and we'll
go ahead and pick Eastern for the time
zone and now we've got local time and
then Universal Time which is obviously
in UTC or GMT whatever you want to call
it so continuing on now the next thing
we want to do is we want to get update
so sudo apt-get update and this is going
to download I want to say your any
updates that you need or the updater but
I'm pretty sure there's all your updates
now I'm just thinking of a side note if
you're overclocked hopefully this
process is going faster than you I ended
up having to reinstall everything on my
PI the first time I went through this
and it might have failed for some of you
guys too when I change the memory split
settings my PI just stopped working so I
had to go through and do it again and
then it actually did it did work but
currently my raspberry pi is no longer
overclocked so if yours is overclocked
hopefully that went faster for you than
it did for me but anyway so the next
thing that we want to do once that is
done running is now sudo apt-get upgrade
and go through that same kind of junk
again and just wait so I'm gonna pause
while we're going through it again oh
and then you can free up some space
absolutely as we upgrade don't worry
you'll fill it back in a minute okay
once that is done now we want to do is
actually let's go ahead and get a new or
newest firmware update and what we're
gonna want to do is if you have all
already been watching my tutorials then
you already have rpi update but if you
don't I will try to remember to post the
link in the bottom for the RPI update
info let's see if I can get this to come
in try my best just copy and paste into
this bad boy it's not gonna let me do it
let's see possible RPI updates already
in here let's try this then we'll do
sudo RPI - update these thumb we already
have it oh I think the Lord anyway so it
looks like if you've had a newer version
of Raspberry Pi it already has RPI
update installed so you won't have to go
get it if you don't then check out one
of my previous tutorials for manually
updating your firmware and you should
already have RPI update installed I was
worried because I've actually since that
video I think I've reinstalled my yeah I
love that completely formatted
reformatted my and reinstalled the
operating system like three or four
times so I just didn't think I had it
anymore but I do so anyways run that and
you'll be updating your firmware and so
I'm gonna pause the video again and
we'll restart once this is finished
alrighty once you've done that that was
probably the longest one of them all for
me at least the next thing that we're
going to need to do is indeed reboot I
didn't see any errors in mine if you got
errors and you'll just have to redo it
but if you didn't see any errors errors
next thing you want to do is do sudo
reboot and that's gonna obviously reboot
and so once we're done there
we'll continue again alrighty everybody
welcome back and let's go ahead and
continue right along next thing that
we're gonna want to do is change our
password it's probably the best idea
because we're going to be making web
server out of this and if anybody knows
you're running a web server off your PI
then they already know your credentials
so to change your password
all you do is sudo passwd and username
and this is going to come up with enter
a you a new UNIX password and so for
this I'm going to enter my own password
and it's going to again and it'll be
updated you'll also enter a root user
password pressure with my sequel but
we'll get to that so the next thing that
we want to do once we've done that is
install Apache and PHP so to do this
what we're gonna need is sudo apt-get
install and we'll install apache2 PHP 5
and a live Apache 2 mod and we want the
PHP 5 with it that should be it always
good idea to check your line let's see
apt-get and get there we go so now that
this is going to do is go ahead and
install apache2 in PHP 5 on your
Raspberry Pi and we're gonna need more
space that's good with me and continuing
right along and so I'm gonna go ahead
and pause it as this is going through
this and we'll restart again
alright everybody once we've done that
the next thing that we might want to
have is some sort of database and the
most popular one is probably my SQL or
my sequel and the way that we're going
to go ahead and get that is we've sudo
apt-get and we want to install MySQL -
server yep
server and then my SQL - client PHP 5
MySQL so that's going to go ahead and do
hopefully if that runs through for us is
start installing my sequel so again yet
another pause while it does this and
you'll get this question as far as Stix
disks nevermind just hit yes ah and then
once you have gotten so far it will ask
you if you want to change the root user
password and for that I would highly
recommend that you do such a thing so in
this case I'm gonna put that in there
and it will have you repeat it and it
will continue right along pausing again
alrighty once you have made it through
all of that the next thing that we're
gonna need to do is restart Apache -
quite simple sudo service service Apache
to restart and that'll go ahead and
restart it up for us
and once this is done it should go
pretty quick yeah so eventually we will
indeed change up and possibly do a
tutorial at least on dynamic DNS but for
now obviously it we don't have a domain
name so it's just going to use a local
address basically for our server name
and we will get to viewing the web page
in just a minute but the next thing we
want to do is let's go ahead and open up
our PHP info page so sudo sudo nano and
we want to go into VAR w w slash and
then phpinfo dot php' and that's going
to open up an empty page for us and now
we're going to create the information
that we need now within here we're
actually making ourselves a PHP page so
you're gonna need PHP tags and then in
here we want to put in PHP info and
that's pretty much it that's all we
really need here
so we'll go ahead and control X yes the
same name and now we've made our PHP
info page so if we pop over to our
internet browser let's go I know there's
one down there but I mean I think that
surf is faster than this one instance
right downloading anything or use net
surf so we shall wait and what we're
gonna want to do is just put in your
computer's local IP address it's usually
going to be 192 168 0 and then like your
computer's number in this case or in my
case this is computer 12 so it's
192.168.0.1 we're gonna look for is
slash phpinfo dot php' so if we enter
that we should be brought to our PHP
info page so to speak I guess it's just
going to take like 4 years to do it in
this browser or maybe it's just not
gonna do it in this browser at all let's
open up the other browser if not I'll
just drag over a chrome on my other
computers on them okay one more time so
192 168 point 0.12 slash PHP in photo ok
this will take us there there we go
ok so as you can see we're connected
just to our local machine eventually you
can make your local machine use a dime
like with dynamic DNS and use a domain
name and actually access it and
everything to be awesome but for now
we're just going to use our local IP and
I would be willing to guess I think at
the moment we could actually use the the
actual IP address as well which is why
security is important
let me test that I'm gonna find out for
sure just just because I'm curious
all right anyway I wanted to make sure
but yes so far I am unable to use it
with the actual IP address but I bet you
could open up a specific port and access
it and there might already be a pre open
port so anyway just just take warning of
that if you're if you are doing this and
you're going to eventually maybe put up
a website or someone is to learn your IP
address and the correct port to get into
your Raspberry Pi just understand you
are connected to the Internet you did
just install a web server to your
Raspberry Pi and chances are your
Raspberry Pi is operating on the exact
same network as your other computers so
just understand what you're doing so
anyway that's that that's a PHP info and
then obviously I mean now it's a web
server so for example we come back over
here and we can sudo you know slash bar
/ww slash example dot peach let's grab a
quick PHP page and in here we'll just
and we'll just echo out like I don't
know hey this is awesome and you're all
awesome right all right so anyway we'll
just do something like that control X
yes to save and are just save to that
same page and now it's example dot PHP
so we can pop over here and instead of
PHP info tie PHP we can go example dot
PHP and it obviously hey this is awesome
right so anyway that is a basic and I
mean basic tutorial on how to install or
basically convert your raspberry pi into
a web server now there's obviously a lot
of things that need to be done before it
could be actually a web page and a
secure web page right and I probably
will eventually get to at least doing
the dynamic DNS part just so you could
actually turn your Raspberry Pi into a
website it's a web server
and then later on you can actually use
that instead of being like a website for
people to look at you can use it as a
way to kind of like remote access your
entire home network basically so you can
do some pretty cool stuff with that
capability so eventually we will get to
that but I just wanted to get through
all the basics for you guys I think it's
pretty exciting it's pretty cool and
then also you can start messing around
with this stuff so like if you're not
really comfortable about buying like a
VPS because you don't really know how to
do it but you're tired of your web host
sucking or whatever this is a good way
to kind of segue yourself into the
operation of a VPS and then also you
know like you don't have to pay for
hosting of websites you can do it all
yourself and if you just have like a
little bitty static website like
sometimes it just makes sense is by
around a little computer and host that
static website off of it and I'm pretty
sure a Raspberry Pi would host a static
page really really well so anyway that's
that that's going to conclude this
tutorial hope you guys enjoy it hope you
guys are enjoying your Raspberry Pi it's
a whole lot of fun at least in my
opinion and it can teach you all kinds
of stuff and if you ever just screw up
you just reinstall the operating system
and go again and I guess if you really
royally screwed up just buy another pie
so anyway I'm just absolutely loving my
pie hopefully you guys are too as always
thank you for watching thank you for
your support your subscriptions and
until next time